静岡はー
雨が強いぞ
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
ちょっとまって
エアコンが無いから暑いんだけど
うあっ
びっくりした、死ぬかと思った
きょうはねー
ソフトバンクの箱なんですけども
大事なのはこの中ですよ
おい
こちら
なんかねぇよくわかんないんだけど買っちゃったんです
銀座を歩いてると、そのなんかソフトバンクの店員さんがねなんか
これは日本には800台しかないし
世界には4000個かな？4000個ぐらいしかないよって言われて
で、もうなんかよくわかんないんですけど買っちゃいましたね
スターウォーズのなんか新キャラクターらしいです
ロボットですね新時代ですよ
スターウォーズのロボットを買いました
もうちょっと
僕もわかんない　スターウォーズあんまり見たことないけど
なんか丸いね
ねまあよく学び、よく食べ、良く動く、まあそういったロボットですね
なんかホログラフィックとか出せるそうです
だぁほんとにレアものらしくて
一昨日から一昨日の夜中に急に発表されて
急にしはじ・・・売り出されたんですけれども
数が少ないのと
スターウォーズファンにとってはたまらない1品らしいです
とりあえずなあ　あれだよ
おお
ＢＢって書いてあります
こっから何が出てくるかですね
カラカラッ・・・
なにこれ・・・
あ使い方も
わコワ
これ大丈夫なの
なんか変な円盤と
わー怖い怖い
わーとれちゃった
顔だけとれちゃった
これ大丈夫なの
ぱちっ
わーすごい落ちなくなる
とりあえずこいつがすごい動きをするという話を聞いたので
ちょっと動かしてみたいわけよ
つないでおいておいてダウンロードしてねみたいな
何もわからんわ
どういうことや
これでいいのかな
でもわかんないんだよね
わっなんか 動いた
光った光った
えっ
光ったよ
カチッカチッカチッ
えっ
ええ怖い怖い
えとっていいのかな
かちっ
うわっ
くっついちゃった
とっていいですか
えっええ動いた動いた
わー怖い怖い怖い
とっていいですか？！
ちょっと一回とってみよう
はっ
ウソウソ
こんにちは
カモン
・・・ん
ノンノンノン　カモン
なんか生きてるのは分かるけど
なっなん何がしたいんだろこいつは
めっちゃキョロキョロしてますね今
とりあえずお前充電器に戻ろう
でね　これ　アプリをダウンロードすることが大事的な感じだったんですけど
アプリをダウンロードしてみたいと思います
お腹空いたの？
さーーーー
ｗｗｗｗ
そんな回転するか
あー止まんなくなっちゃった
ごめんごめん
大丈夫かお前マジで
わわわわ
わーびっくりした
なに
ゴメン
はい頭触ると怒るよね
なんかわかってきたぞどういうやつか
カチ
うわ
わーびっくりした
えーうそなに今の
ごめんなさい
でもなんか可愛く見えてきちゃった
うわ？
うわびっくりした
よしきた
アプリインストール完了しました
なんかこいつ専用のアプリみたいなやつがあります
おっドルートスをオンにして・・・
ドライブ
目の前の地面にＢＢ－８を置いてください
はい
ウォー
あっちいけ
よしよし
おーすごい
動く
アクセスを・・・わーちょわー
ちょ次のモードで遊んでわーーーーーーーー
これだめだ机でするもんじゃねーわ
いろいろなんか他にもできることがあるらしいです
操作もできるしパトロールさせれるらしいし
スターウォーズファンとかにしたら、
わー、あれかとかなるかもしれないんですけど
よくわかんないんでスターウォーズを観ようと思いました
とても変わったロボットを買ってしまいました
まーなんか高性能なのかどうなのかっていうのよくわからないけど
なんか丸いしすごいですね
お前すごいぞ
ではまた次回の動画でお会いしましょう
じゃあな
ｗｗｗ
すごいのかどうだかなんかわかんないよ